let me jump to the story from the wall
street journal house back's creation of
commission
on january 6th capital riot former
president trump and gop leaders urged
republicans to oppose the bill
so we're going to have some kind of what
9 11 style commission
on the capital riots and i'm sorry man
the the republican party i understand
it's it's it's
better than the democrats for a lot of
reasons but why didn't they ever do
anything about black lives matter antifa
when they had the power to do it
well we never really had the power to do
it under under president trump um
2017. well i mean they weren't paying
attention the firs
well the first two years of of the trump
administration i mean i would argue that
the the black lives matter and antifa
protests that really rampaged across the
country burned down federal courthouses
they burned down a police precinct and i
think minnesota i mean they they were
last year though so you know republicans
had lost the house at that point but
that's what i mean i mean i think that
most
of the violent protests that we saw
happened after the republicans had lost
control of all the
three branches of government how many
how many how many uh riots were there
over the past four years from far
leftists i don't know if the top 100s
well i mean i would say probably
thousands i would absolutely say
thousands that just
not a single one not a single instance
in from you know in uh 2017 and 2018
warranted two republicans any kind of
action
but the democrats get one and they
are going nuclear for months a 9 11
style commission
this is the problem the democrats will
will like will stub their toe
and blame the far right and scream they
have their lungs and the republicans go
okay
okay okay and then you can literally get
billions of dollars of damage
and the republicans won't even send in
national guard to stop it
trump will be like please please in the
national guard and the democrats in
these cities are like no and he goes
okay well i mean i think part of the
reason for that
is that the democrat party i mean
they have the largest super pac in the
world i mean they have
you know a billion dollar corporate
media mainstream media that does nothing
but fly cover for them and in it
and parrot their talking points right
sure sure but
why why do republican candidates care
more about the opinions of the new york
times and their own constituents
that so look it's it's a great question
and it's part of what i think the
republican party
i mean look if you're a candidate right
and you're going to go out there on the
parapet
be a republican be a conservative in
this day and age
you have to know going into him that if
the media the main not not all the media
right and i'm i'm not trying to
they're i'm not trying to paint anybody
with you know broad strokes here
but you got to know that the media is
coming after you definitely and you're
not doing your job
you know that if they are coming after
you you're probably
over the target so to speak to use
military parlance right
um that's how i look at things if
they're attacking me i know that i'm
representing the people and to me
ultimately that's what this job is about
this job is about
is about representing the people and
being there for them which is why
i mean look i think 2020 like running
a campaign in 2020 was an unbelievable
experience for me
because i didn't know anything about
campaigning it was the first time i've
ever done it so i learned a lot
but one of the things you know one of
the things that's just so important for
republicans right moving forward is
is is not being beholden to
like the big money right we had 45 000
individual donors because of that we
weren't really beholden to
you know any sort of special interest
corporation or even the republican party
even though
i'm a republican running on the ticket
it gave me the freedom
to to represent the people in the best
way that i
saw fit and i think we did that to great
effect and we're going to take it to the
next level on the senate race but
yes you as a republican in this day and
age
you know you have to be willing to stand
on the parapet and take shots from the
from the media because
if you're advocating for for what you
believe and what the people that you
represent believe you're gonna take
they're coming after you
i just got very little faith in uh
anyone to actually
be a leader in terms of standing up to
the establishment which is
mostly democrat some republicans there's
a reason why people like marjorie taylor
green
even after everything she posted and
said and then apologized for and it's
because she's feisty
she's a fighter she fights she fights
like donald trump fought and so she
raises what three point something
million dollars in the first quarter
so they can criticize her and smear her
all she wants and she revels in it
and people see that and they're like
finally someone is standing up
ted cruz goes to cancun or whatever
right so it's got the power outage
the freeze in texas ted cruz flies so he
flew to cancun is that where he went
yeah i think just to take his family
down there regardless
the media freaks out and then he's
flying right back overnight
i'd have been like you know what not the
media's freaking out i'm gonna take a
picture of myself my feet up
sipping a martini being like is this
what you want don't play stupid games
now he said he was just there to fly his
family there and back sure whether you
want to believe him or not i think he
was going on vacation and honestly i
don't care
what makes what you know what i do care
about well i'll say this first
probably a bad move to be a
representative of your community
in a time of crisis and be like i'm
gonna go to the beach nah i'd like
you know running for office being in
office is more than just
showing up in congress and talking it's
being a leader for your community and
and helping build that culture
and lead by example but if you want to
go on vacation i'm not going to cry
about it
i'll tell you what really bothers me
that the media screamed and he was right
back
oh no no oh geez no oh don't look at me
i don't care what the new york times has
to say
about these people i'm sick of the lies
from the media i'm sick of the of the
fact that
for for four years the republicans in
the senate
didn't do much of anything with what was
going on i remember
from 2016 1718 we knew censorship was a
very serious problem
and the banning of donald trump's most
ardent supporters was going to result in
republicans getting
defeated republicans can't even express
their own opinions
how could they expect to win at this
point and they did not i agree
look look i know i know you know what
i'm writing at you you know where i'm
going with this right like
it's happening to me right now you know
i look
if you you want to think you talk about
big tech censorship i i not i'm not
section 230 is one thing i don't think i
necessarily support that because it
hurts people like you right
like but they're they're appealing
section to there or yeah they're
repealing section 230 hurts
it needs to be reformed it needs to be
reformed for sure right something needs
to be done about big tests or state
level laws what you're seeing texas
yes but look at what's happening to me
i'm a senate i'm a senate candidate
in the state of pennsylvania in the
arguably the biggest
senate race in the country right senate
control depends on the state of
pennsylvania
right and go to google right now right
punt just do it right now for you for
your viewers like search
sean parnell senate on google and see if
you can find my campaign website
nbc news is the first link twitter
account so
i raise money on my campaign site the
only way i raise digital money
is on that campaign side google has a
monopoly on search engines right so you
go and go you
you got to be a forensic data analyst to
find my website on google
now if you're watching the show go to
yahoo or go to bing
or go to duckduckgo and punch in sean
parnell senate and see what comes up
let's go to bing yeah just just see just
see what comes out
bing sean parnell just do a search yeah
hey there you go it's first it's the
number one so here's the th here's
sean parnell former governor alaska is
actually the card that pops up
but your website is yeah so yeah but so
that's the point so
look candidates there's we already
talked about like there's a direct
correlation be
between your ability to raise money as a
candidate and getting your message out
the republican party
they don't give you money you know like
it it's all about your ability to raise
money now
you want to talk about big tech having
their finger on the thumb or on their
finger
their finger on the scale uh tipping
tipping the scale in one direction now
google any other candidate in the state
of pennsylvania who you
who would you be running against i mean
there's there's just google google a guy
named john fetterman the uh lieutenant
government
i got him yeah just google him see if
his website comes up on google first
thing
first thing is his twitter and then
governor.pa.gov then johnfetterman.com
that okay
there you go so if you're on google the
primary mechanism that everybody in
and he's running for the senate and he's
running for the senate so my opponent
right now
has or or a potential opponent right now
this is a primary right there's a
primary right there's a republican
primary
but my point is they have a distinct
advantage right now and this is this is
big
tech i'm telling you this is big tech
putting their putting their thumb on the
scale
helping one side over the other so yes
there needs to be reform and by the way
this hinders my ability to to to
raise money and get my message out so to
hey
smash smash my win red link and
contribute to my campaign because
you can't find my you can't find it on
the website and i'm gonna need all the
help i can get in the senate race in
pennsylvania
you do but i think it might be too late
or uh
so what what year was it that alex and
milo and everybody got banned was it
2018
yeah that was that was a couple of years
ago a couple years ago 17 or 18.
paul joseph watson got his instagram
taken down and it was just like selfies
in the sun or whatever
banned from facebook milo alex now
people might not like them but a lot of
people do like them and they were some
of trump's biggest supporters
and it was obvious get rid of the
largest communities where people gather
to support
donald trump and other populist
politicians
and you will beat them and it happened
it happened over and over and over again
it kept happening and i talked about
this because i made a segment
something about republicans are too
stupid to deal with censorship to save
their own careers
and here we go now they're they're not
going to win they're going to win where
it's deep red
but i mean i i will say surprisingly the
polling was was tremendously favorable
to republicans
in uh in the 2020 election for sure but
right now
with what we're seeing out of you know
pennsylvania for instance philadelphia
specifically
30-point lead for the progressive
all right i don't think we're going to
see a republican you know huge turnout
in the general because it's just
it's a city philadelphia philadelphia is
tough but i will tell you like in the
look this is what i mean like this is
what i mean about going to certain
places the first week of the campaign
i went into south philly i went to the
italian market and i talked to business
owners there
showing up matters it doesn't mean
you're going to get doesn't mean you're
going to get a majority of the vote
but you've got to show up for people
right and you know i've been on this
show with you four
times it's not like i'm a i'm a crazy
right-wing bomb thrower
truthfully i'm a consensus builder i'm i
consider myself a leader right
you know when i was in afghanistan i led
the most diverse platoon you could
possibly imagine rich next to poor black
next to white christians next to
atheists next to muslims democrats next
to republicans next to socialists
you know we figured out a way to make it
work in one of the most hostile regions
on the planet because we figured out a
way to look past our many differences as
americans
and unite under a common banner and
fight for a common mission if i can do
that in afghanistan or a remote hilltop
and one of the most hostile regions on
the planet we sure as i can do it here
in the country
that's my message everywhere yet you
can't find me
on google that's a problem it's a real
problem do you know when the republican
primary is going to be
it for senate yeah it's a year it's a
year so that may
if in case you're wondering yes that's a
long time yes i just threw up in my
mouth a little bit but the problem is is
and i do think campaigns generally last
way too long but
we've already got candidates in the race
raising a ton of money especially on the
democrat side
and if we wait to get in you could find
yourself in a 10 million dollar hole and
that's impossible to dig yourself
out you know so um yeah i mean i suppose
there's some optimism in that uh the
democrats have a very very slim
control right now and they've gone back
to sleep and ratings are in the gutter
because
absolutely don't pay attention anymore
look 2022 is going to be look
we talked about the the ballot questions
that should give you a little inkling
about
where public sentiment is with regards
to
these lockdowns for example or or
control which is the
really a core core pillar of the cam of
democrats or radical democrats
um and so i think 2022 is going to be a
great year
uh for for republicans conservatives
leaders uh in pennsylvania pennsylvania
is
absolutely winnable absolutely winnable
uh i i personally think we're going to
win pennsylvania so who
are the senators right now for
pennsylvania uh senator pat toomey who's
his seats being vacated right so he's a
republican
and so there's an open seat right it's
an open seat so you wouldn't be
campaigning against an incumbent you've
got an open seat the first time there's
an open seat in pennsylvania in a very
long time
you've got senator bob casey who is a
democrat and
he's been there uh for a couple times
are they both up for re-election or it's
it's this uh just the oh yes
yes so this is an open seat right so a
republican is retiring
um and so yes biggest
senate race in the country so if this
goes democrat you lose
you lose control of the senate yeah it's
already you know the tiebreaker goes to
the democrats because of kamala harris
so
we had this the senate seat in
pennsylvania is a must-hold seat
it's it's a must hold it it is because
of
mansion mansion is the west virginia
democrat who's
democrat and the democrats are outraged
because they call him like the guy
the gatekeeper the key holder that's
right if you lose pennsylvania
and it goes democrat mansions out
doesn't matter anymore now
the republicans and the democrats win
you're 100 percent correct and and i
mean kristen siena
senator sienna right out of arizona is
sort of holding the line with senator
manchin as well
right but without pennsylvania without
pennsylvania the path
to the majority is through arizona right
against
against senator kelly a democrat or in
new hampshire
right um pennsylvania that's why that's
why my campaign motto is when
pennsylvania save america
because we are the true hedge against
the radicalism of the
new progressive left this is 2022 this
is 2022.
so it's also possible that republicans
take back the house which
even 538 right now is saying republicans
are likely going to win back the house
i'm not entirely confident unless we
start seeing some actual populists you
know
run and win a many win uh many of these
seats
because if we just get more you know
establishment types like cheney's or
kinzinger's then just
candidates matter candidates matter a
lot and
it's not just about like i cannot if
you're out there and you're thinking of
running for
office whether it's local state federal
it's not just about your ability to
articulate a message
okay it's about your ability to
fundraise and and it is not
easy right fundraising means that you're
on like people
think that me running a campaign first
of all is like
on stage with trump like at a rally in
front of 50 000 people and yeah that
happens and yeah that was a
it was an unbelievable experience to be
a part of that but that's one percent of
it
it's like five hours a day on the phone
calling people cold calling people have
you ever done sales calls try cold
calling people and just and say hey
you know and then asking for like 2900
bucks see how often you get hung up on
see how often people tell you no but you
have to be relentless with it and
and what i see is that all too often
candidates aren't willing to do that and
but but you got to do it you know one of
the biggest challenges for republicans
is when you're dealing with a message of
we're going to give you free stuff
versus be responsible
for yourself and go work hard i think i
know where people are gonna lean towards
i don't know about that tim i don't know
how i i know that
i know that like and i'll tell you
talking to business owners like one of
the main
issues that they're facing right now and
whether it's in the restaurant industry
in the manufacturing sector or whatever
is that we're paying people more uh to
stay home on unemployment than go to
work that's a problem right
and people are choosing to do it yeah
well that's right i mean well look if
you're
if you're if you're a a mother of three
and you've got three little kids and you
have an opportunity to stay home with
your kids for for a few weeks and
and spend time with them you're going to
take that and i'm not going to fault you
right um well the gop tweeted you see
that they tweeted what did they say that
you know
more women are choosing to stay at home
and be with their children than go to
work and all of these like twitter
conservatives were like what is wrong
with you i don't know i don't pay i
look i'm focused on winning the senate
in pennsylvania in 2022 i don't i can't
speak to any of that but like
our job as as leaders i think you know
in in
in part of my core philosophy is
you know my personal mission is to go to
go to washington when we win do
everything that i can to shrink
the size and scope of the federal
government because i think that too much
consolidated power in washington i
believe that there's a direct
correlation between that consolidated
power
and less freedom in our lives right and
so
we can shrink the size and scope of the
federal government we can divert as much
power back to the states as humanly
possible because ultimately the states
are the experts every
state like states or the they know what
they need right uh
and so more freedom in our lives is a
good thing and then when i'm done with
that i mean
i'm not a career politician you're not
going to see me in washington for 40
years but you bet after a couple terms
i'm going to
get myself a farm in western
pennsylvania and probably never talk to
anybody again but
but but yeah i know i know you do but
but the point is
is that i i think by and large it's our
job to advocate
for things like pro pro growth policies
right like
low taxes letting people keep more of
their own money rolling back regulations
to make sure that pennsylvania is a
place where people can start a business
and not feel like it's too onerous of a
process right
protecting the energy industry
understanding that there are a couple
different pillars underneath that issue
one of which is the economic issue
people paying more for gas right now
than they probably should more to heat
their homes
that economic issue disproportionately
affects middle income to lower income
families like we don't want that right
we want those families to be lifted up
and keep more of their money so
to the extent that we can be energy
independent it's good for middle middle
class lower income people but there's
also significant national security
implications for it you look at what's
happening now right
joe biden cancels the keystone xl
pipeline puts 10 000 plus union workers
out of work
hurts our energy independence all with a
stroke of a pen
while approving and rolling back
sanctions on russia
to to approve their pipeline so so joe
biden is literally
creating jobs in russia helping their
energy independ independence
helping the russian economy to allow
them to export natural gas
all around the world while all while
they're on the border of ukraine
if imagine though listen imagine if
president trump did that
they would be calling him a russian
asset well you already were
but you know oh of course they already
were but but yes this proves it
yeah this proves it but you see my point
right and so uh
energy independence is something that's
important it's a major pillar of the
economy
in pennsylvania and healthcare is a big
deal right
the gop has not had a good answer on
healthcare
for a long time and i think you know
part of my
platform is having a good market-based
innovative plan for healthcare like we
all talk about the republican talking
points of letting insurance companies
compete across state lines more
flexibility
more choice means lower cost for the
consumer and and a more diverse
health care plan offering all of that's
great uh in talking about association
health care plans of the idea of small
businesses being able to band together
to have the same purchasing power
as large corporations that's good right
but what if we
like think outside the box for a second
and take things a step further and say
why don't we let individuals
of a similar age sex demographic
with similar healthcare needs
individuals band together on app based
technology
it essentially becomes an insurance pool
you have millions of people on
you gotta call it a platinum plan gold
plan silver plan whatever
but people that like 25 year olds have
similar health care needs right like
it's not perfect right but you can
invest money you pay a certain amount of
money on a monthly fee for a healthcare
app you become a member of that
healthcare plan
and and you allow individuals now to
have the same purchasing power as large
corporations republicans
need to need to start thinking outside
the box on on having
good pragmatics policy solutions
to make our lives better it's true but
you go to a regular person and say
they want you to come up with some plan
for banding together we're going to give
you free stuff
well the problem is is that you know
first of all it's not
it's not virtuous to take someone else's
money
tax someone else and give their money to
someone there's a lot of people who
don't care
well just give me the free stuff i don't
care they will care because
the problem is is eventually you run out
of other people's money and then
the democrats come out and blame the
republicans saying it's your fault for
not raising the debt ceiling or whatever
and so you look at what's going on with
these police and they defund the police
there's then no cops to deal with crime
and they say see look the cops aren't
even doing anything anyway
they use the problem they create to then
advocate
for more destruction of the system well
that you can't just be like free
healthcare
which what they keep saying and regular
people who don't know
are like i'll vote for that and they're
like okay now how do we do it well you
can't so let's just fake it till you
make it
so they're like print more money i guess
i think aoc actually said deficit spend
oh right just basically you're just
talking about stripping away the
the value of the working class from
their savings to fund
health care yeah it's it's distribution
well it's not you know i mean just
health care if you're looking at like
so joe biden i think in his first
hundred days of as president and infuse
something like two and a half trillion
dollars of cash
into the economy and what you're seeing
is not just a lackluster jobs report i
think they they expected
you know close to a million jobs they
got 250 thousand absolutely horrible
right so there was that
in addition to inflation just this month
4.2 percent
right now inflation means the dollar has
individuals have less purchasing power
their dollar is worth less it's
basically
inflation is a tax on everybody and
again
it disproportionately affects middle to
lower income people when you want to
look at inflation you see
inflation reflected in the cost of our
commodities like try to go
and buy lumber to build a deck on your
house and you're going to spend
probably five six times as much on that
wood right
so i i inflation is not just on our
doorstep it's here
you know joe biden for all he talks
about no he's not gonna tax people that
make less than 400
000 a year first of all i i wouldn't
believe that he's going to
okay uh but inflation is a tax
on the middle com it's attack it's on on
middle-income families right
um not being energy independent
essentially is
a tax on the middle income lower income
families so
what what the point that i'm building to
here is that it's our job as leaders
uh in the republican party to have
policies and be able to specifically
articulate those policies that advocate
for pro-growth positions and they can't
just be talking points
you have to talk about why it's
important to make you know to advocate
for policies to make pennsylvania
prosperous right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you